what's going to happen when uh when
robots can do art better than humans LOL
like well we'll see in 20 years in 20
years and 20 years and now you have ai
art winning competitions and it's funny
because
robots are essentially the robot behind
you by the way the robot behind me oh
nice
um robots are really good careful what
you say yeah oh God I'll be careful um
that's not like one of the Chinese ones
with a gun on it right oh okay uh I'll
play that uh what we'll see depending on
what you say yeah okay robots are really
good at showing the limitations of the
human mind in categories that we didn't
believe we were limited before I I think
that humans have this idea intrinsically
that we have like some type of like
Innovative Creative Drive that is just
outside of the bounds of physical
understanding and with a sophisticated
enough program we see that maybe that's
not actually true and that's a really
scary thing philosophically to deal with
because we feel like we're very special
right we own the planet we make
computers and the idea that you can
start to get these robots that can do
things that's like okay you can do math
fine okay you can do calculations
because fine but you can't do art that's
the human stuff and then when they start
to do that it's like oh shoot and that
terrifies you a little bit like a losing
the human species losing control of our
dominance
I don't think it's necessarily losing
control over dominance I mean I guess
like a Skynet thing could come in at
some point but I think I think it more
it it brings us to this really
fundamental level of like what does it
mean to be human what is it that we're
good at
um what should we be doing with
technology we never really asked that
question in the western world it's
always the technology is like normative
and that technology equals good and more
technology equals better that's been
like the default assumption in fact if
you ask a lot of people how do you know
if civilization has progressed over the
past 100 or 200 years they don't say we
have better relationships we um you know
have longer marriages we blah blah
they'll say technology is improved we've
got crazy phones we've got crazy
computers and um the idea that more
technology might be bad has never even
crossed somebody's mind unless it's used
for like a really bad thing so well it's
interesting we kind of think as more and
more automation is happening we're going
to get more and more meaning from things
like being artists and doing creative
Pursuits and here's like oh [ __ ]
if the r if the creative proceeds
they're also being automated then what
are we going to gain meaning from what
are the activities from what you'll gain
meaning you know my whole life I've been
working on artificial intelligence
systems there's been different
revolutions one of them is is the is the
machine learning Revolution and
it's interesting to build up intuition
and destroy that intuition about what is
and isn't solvable by machines I think
um for the longest time I grew up
thinking go is not the game will go is
not solvable uh because my understanding
of AI systems is ultimately that it's
it's fundamentally a search mechanism
that is fundamentally going to be Brute
Force there's no shortcuts sure like I
try like if it can't solve the traveling
salesman problem it's not even going to
be able to give you an approximation so
most interesting problems are giant
travel salesman problem and then so of
course it's not gonna be able to solve
that and then you then the Deep learning
Revolution made you realize holy [ __ ]
these large neural networks are the
giant number of knobs is able to
actually somehow uh estimate functions
that can do a pretty good job of
understanding deep representation of a
thing whether that's a game of Go or
whether it's the human natural language
or if it's images and video or um audio
and even actions and different video
games and actions of Robotics and so on
and then do you realize with diffusion
models and different different
generative models you start to realize
holy [ __ ] it can actually generate not
not just
interesting
representations or interesting
manifestations of the representations of
forms but it's able to do something that
impresses humans in its creativity it's
it's beautiful in the way we think of
art is beautiful like it surprises us
and makes us chuckle it makes us sit
back in awe and all those kinds of
things and yet the thing that it seems
to struggle with the most is the
physical world currently
so that that's a counterintuitive we
humans think that it's um it's pretty
trivial the being able to pick up a cup
being able to like write with a pen like
in the physical space would think that's
trivial we give ourselves respect for
being great artists and great uh
mathematicians and all that kind of
stuff and that seems to be much easier
than the physical space our bodies are
really cool yeah there is a um I don't
know it's probably Asimov or something
there was some science fiction writer
that had a short story and it was like
an alien that had landed on Earth and it
was describing our bodies from a totally
alien perspective and when you think
about all the things we can do it's
pretty cool we can you know climb
through a whole multitude of
environments we can exist in a multitude
of temperatures we can manipulate things
um just with our hands and you know the
way that we can interact with things
around us and yeah we're very capable on
like a physical level even though like
you said we think about ourselves like
oh well human beings have really big
brains and we do we're really
intelligent as well but yeah our bodies
are pretty cool too
and it's a fascinating hierarchical
biological system like um
that were made up of a bunch of
different
like living organisms that all don't
know about the big picture of our body
and it's all functioning its own little
local world and it's doing its thing but
together it has a it forms a super
resilient system all of that comes from
a very uh compressed
encoding of what makes a human you start
with the DNA and it builds up from a
single cell to a giant organism I mean
and because of the DNA through the
evolution process you can constantly
create new humans and new living
organisms that adapt to the environment
like that resilience to the physical
world
it seems like running the whole earth
over again
the whole evolutionary process over
again is uh might be the only way to do
it so to create a robot that actually
adapts
is as resilient to the dynamic world
might be a really difficult problem
possibly well I was going to say like in
a programming environment you can do
things on time scales that are
impossible in the real world right like
the benefit to Ai and computers is a
computational they can compute so much
data so quickly whereas on human
timetables we have to wait when you talk
about Evolution
um you know it's generation after
generation after generation you know
maybe in a virtual environment that
could be simulated and then those
changes Could Happen a lot quicker with
this in a human time scale but you have
to look at Earth
at a Quantum as a quantum mechanical
system the computation is happening
super fast this is a giant computer
doing a giant simulation so just because
for us humans it's slow there's like
trillions of organisms involved in you
Destiny being you sure but the next
iteration of like from Human to human
even if under the quantum love is a lot
of stuff going on you talk about like um
like changes in DNA for instance right
like that's happening from a generation
a generation time scale like in a
virtual environment that could
theoretically happen well it already is
there's like protein folding like huge
cloud computing probably ml stuff that's
like working on doing all that stuff and
it'll run like trillions and trillions
of simulations you know every second of
stuff maybe not every second but still
slower than the actual protein folding
much slower the that's for the problem
of solving protein folding uh to
estimate the 3D structure but the actual
body does the actual protein folding way
faster so like where the question is can
we shortcut the simulation of human
evolution try to figure out how to build
up an organism without simulating all
the details because we have to simulate
all the details of biology were screwed
we don't have our chair we'd have to put
something in a pond and then watch it
for that might be a million years way to
do it sure that's what the universe most
likely is it's a kind of simulation
created by a teenager in their basement
to to try to see what happens it's a
it's a computer game that might be the
most efficient way to create interesting
organisms but within this system is
perhaps possible to create
other robots that will be of use and
will entertain us in the way that other
humans entertain us and that's a really
interesting of course problem but it's
surprising how difficult it has been
to create systems that operate in the
physical world and operate in that
physical world in a way that's safe to
humans and interesting to humans because
there's also the human factor the human
robot interaction to me that's like the
most interesting problem to figure out
how to do that well and uh so
Elon Musk and others Boston Dynamics
have worked on legged robots so I I
really care about legged robots
those are super interesting how to make
them such that they're
able to operate successfully in a
dynamic environment super tricky they're
like they're like the dumbest of dogs
speaking of which there's a dog barking
outside I mean it's it's really tricky
to create those kinds of organisms that
live in a in the human world then again
if more and more of us move into the
digital world
so you stream a lot like part of Who You
Are
exists in the digital space the fact
that you have a physical representation
also
maybe more and more will become not
important
I hope that's the case because I bought
a lot of stock in meta and man it's down
met at the company yeah is there some
degree like can you can you can you look
at yourself like Stephen the physical
meat vehicle and then the destiny this
digital space like digital
Avatar do you sense that in a certain
way you're the digital Avatar I've
always tried to keep my on-stream
personality as genuine as possible so
they're one and the same to me I don't
really view them as two separate
entities so but I mean I always view
myself as Stephen the real life person
my Destiny's my online name but no but
because so many your social network is
established the digital space like so
many people know you through the digital
space can there be can we swap out
another person that looks like you
and like an AI system and then that
entity known as Destiny will continue
existing so I mean it must be like there
must be some level of sophistication
that could emulate a human brain I would
imagine right
probably the text not there yet but well
the question is what's the level of
sophistication of the audience that
would recognize that something has
changed
like it's the touring test yeah how hard
is it to trick your audience your your
large audience of fans that watch your
streams that when you swap out in the AI
that emulates you that nothing has
changed
and the question is do you have to
really simulate so much of the human
brain for that I don't think so probably
not and so I mean like you said a lot of
political discourses just walking down
the tree together so you can probably
emulate a lot of that discussion yeah it
would depend on if you're doing old data
sets and you're training on that and I'm
having conversations about abortion and
Ukrainian vaccines I imagine it could do
it for quite a while the only thing
would be weird is when novel issues pop
up then you probably need a more
sophisticated resemblance of the inner
brain right you have to keep keep
training on the internet so how the
language models and that's the most
incredible breakthroughs is the language
models you just have to keep retraining
the system on Reddit which is actually
what a lot of it is trained on which is
hilarious I do think it's really
interesting that like kind of like funny
problems like the trolley problem that
we can kind of work through our
normative ethical systems on are now
like real questions like if you're
driving a Tesla and it's on autopilot
and you're gonna hit somebody but it can
swerve and hit somebody else like what
what ought to system do like we went
very quickly from fun kind of like
project and philosophy class too we need
to solve this for insurance purposes
like as quickly as possible it's kind of
interesting to think about